PRESIDENT BIDEN MEETS PUTIN TWO
WEEKS FROM TODAY.
>> Martha: GOVERNOR CUOMO
TAKING HEAT FORCING CHILDREN TO
WEAR MASKS UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE
GOING AGAINST STATE AND FEDERAL
HEALTH GUIDANCE.
USING HIS WANING POWER.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
EXPLAIN YOUR HEADLINE.
HE HAS GONE AGAINST THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN LONG ISLAND ANDLY
SHOW A LITTLE PIECE OF WHAT
THEY SAID.
THEY SAID WHEN WE EX MRAINLD TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OUR
STRICTNESS IN KEEPING STUDENTS
SIX FEET APART THEY INDICATED
IT DIDN'T MATTER.
WE WERE DIRECTED MASKS MUST BE
WORN AT ALL TIMES.
WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR UP TO HERE?
>> SO THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
THE GOVERNOR HAS BEEN
FLIP-FLOPPING BACK AND FORTH
WHETHER OR NOT HE IS IN CHARGE
OF SCHOOLS.
IN APRIL OF LAST YEAR WHEN HE
GOT INTO ONE OF HIS MANY BRAWLS
WITH MAYOR BILL DEBLASIO HE
SAID HE WAS IN CHARGE OF
SCHOOLS.
WHEN IT WAS TIME TO OPEN
SCHOOLS HE WASN'T.
NOW WE'RE REACHING ANOTHER
POINT WHERE HIS OWN DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH SAID IF KIDS ARE SIX
FEET APART THEY CAN TAKE OFF
THEIR MASKS.
HE HAS OVERRULED HIS OWN
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH TO STEP IN
AND SAY HE IS IN CHARGE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT CANNOT DO WHAT
SCIENCE SAYS THEY SHOULD.
>> Martha: IT REALLY IS
REMARKABLE BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SCIENCE ON THIS,
THESE KIDS IN MANY CASES, THERE
WERE KIDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO WENT BACK TO SCHOOL IN
SEPTEMBER ALL OVER THE PLACE.
AND IN HIS OWN CITY.
CATHOLIC SCHOOL KIDS WERE IN
SCHOOL.
HOW DOES HE JUSTIFY BECOMING
MORE STRICT WHEN THE NEIGHBOR
DOWN THE STREET HAS BEEN IN
SCHOOL SINCE SEPTEMBER?
>> IT ALSO KIDS IN MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO GO TO MASK OPTIONAL SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE GOTTEN TO THE POINT
WHERE OUR RATE IS SO LOW KIDS
SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN WEARING
MASKS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
NOW THERE IS NO ARGUMENT TO BE
MADE ANYMORE.
UNVACCINATED CHILD HAS THE SAME
CHANCE AS A VACCINATED ADULT OF
GETTING COVID AND LESS
LIKELIHOOD OF PASSING IT ON.
WE REACHED A POINT WHERE NOBODY
SHOULD BE WEARING MASKS IN
SCHOOLS.
IF THEY WANT TO DO THAT THROUGH
THE END OF THE YEAR, THAT'S
FINE.
BUT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES.
IT SHOULD BE A DECISION BETWEEN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT, PARENTS,
DOCTORS, NOT GOVERNOR CUOMO.
>> Martha: A GREAT POINT.
AT THE POINT THAT WE'RE AT
GIVEN THE SCIENCE THAT WE HAVE,
ALLOW THE FAMILIES TO MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISION.
I READ A THREAD ON TWITTER LAST
NIGHT THAT SHOCKED ME ALL THESE
PEOPLE SAYING THEY DON'T WANT
TO TAKE OFF THE MASKS.
THEY AREN'T COMFORTABLE.
THEY FEEL IF THEIR CHILD
DOESN'T HAVE A MASK ON THEY ARE
A THREAT TO EVERYONE AROUND
THEM.
NO SCIENCE TO BACK THAT UP.
POLITICALLY IT'S INTERESTING
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AT THE
DEBLASIO STORY.
IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS
DEBLASIO'S INSTINCT TOLD HIM
STUDENTS SHOULD STAY IN SCHOOL.
PARENTS HAVE TO GO TO WORK.
THEY SHOULD STAY IN SCHOOL.
THEY WILL BE SAFE IN SCHOOL
BEFORE WE KNEW A LOT ABOUT
TRANSMISSION.
HE GOT SHUT DOWN IN A BIG WAY
ON THAT BY GOVERNOR CUOMO.
IT WAS AN INTERESTING MOMENT IN
THIS STORY.
>> I AGREE.
ACTUALLY IT IS FUNNY.
I MENTION IN MY COLUMN.
BILL DEBLASIO WANTED TO OPEN
SCHOOLS AT SO MANY DIFFERENT
POINTS BUT WASN'T STRONG ENOUGH
TO STAND UP TO THE TEACHERS
UNIONS AND GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS
BEEN HANDS OFF AND LET HIM TAKE
THE LEAD ON THIS BECAUSE HE TOO
DOES NOT WANT TO GET INTO A
SCUFFLE WITH THE TEACHERS UNION.
WE HAVE THESE TWO REALLY WEAK
POLITICIANS WHO WANT STAND UP
TO TEACHERS UNIONS AND CONTINUE
TO BE PASSIVE AND NOT DO THE
RIGHT THINGS FOR KIDS.
THEY SEE LEADERSHIP NOT SAYING
IT'S OKAY FOR KIDS TO UNMASK
FINALLY.
IF GOVERNOR CUOMO DID THAT IT
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF THESE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SO AFRAID.
>> Martha: A GREAT POINT.
THE UNIONS MAY HAVE LOST SOME
OF THE POWER AS WE SEE STUDENTS
LEAVING THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM IN DROVES.
THEY STILL ARE BIG CONTRIBUTORS
TO DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGNS.
THAT MAY BE WHAT'S TALKING HERE.
GREAT PIECE AS ALWA